what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
merry christmas eve for those of you
celebrating christmas and happy holidays
to everybody as you can probably tell
i'm still pretty sick but i wanted to
say thank you for an awesome year and i
wanted to show you these really really
awesome promo art images that are going
to be used for merchandise for
spider-man knowing home that you're
going to be able to get soon spider-man
no way home was the perfect holiday gift
for all of us spider-man and marvel fans
and i know we're going to be talking
about it for a while and i know a lot of
us are going to be rocking that merch
and again thank you to everybody who
supports this channel but right now i
got to issue a spoiler alert if you
haven't seen spider-man no way home
these pictures are going to give away
spoilers big time and of course if you
love marvel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos now this first design actually
settles a huge debate among the fandom
right now in no way home toby maguire
and andrew garfield both showed up and
of course we knew that for a while but
we didn't really know how to address the
three of them a lot of people said it
was spider-man's and then some people
like myself said it was spider-man and
this solves the debate it says
men right up front on this design and it
shows all three spider-man right up
front very close all with their awesome
different suits from their own universes
and this is a shirt that i am definitely
going to be getting the next one we have
here is of the three spider-man again
and this one looks like it's from the
final scene because you can see the
scaffolding for the statue of liberty
behind them and if you actually take a
close look and compare toby maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man to the previous design
they're actually the same but i gotta
say i do really like the design of their
suits they really pop out in these
images and not gonna lie i'll probably
get this one too and i'll also probably
get the next one this one's a little bit
more of a cartoon-ish style now again
toby and andrew spider-man they are kind
of the same design and tom's is the same
design from the first promo image as
well but in this one they're all
shooting webs and all coming out of the
portal together so i mean it's still
pretty awesome and i'm still going to be
getting this these are officially
licensed by marvel so sometime pretty
soon i'm assuming you're going to be
able to get these on shirts on merch so
if you like these just be on the lookout
again sorry for the short videos it's
extremely hard to talk right now
hopefully i'll be better soon and be
back at it with the videos but in the
meantime happy holidays to everybody
hope it's a great time for everybody
right now i wish you all the best i love
you all three thousand and i'll see you
next time woof
me
you